[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend sportlich ist heute jede
Menge los was das erfahren wir später
mit dir chr von gut bis nicht ganz so
gut aber guten Abend hier sind unsere
Themen an diesem
Freitag bedrängt und blockiert Bauern
lassen ihre Wut an Minister habbeck aus
eine Aktion die den meisten achtern
deutlich zu weit
geht es ist angerichtet
Restaurantbetreiber hoffen dass Ihnen
die Gäste trotz hörerer Mehrwertsteuer
nicht davon
laufen schlechte Generalprobe gutes
Zeichen die Quali zum entscheidenden
springen der vier chanzenournee läuft
für Andreas Wellinger er
mau Wirtschaftsminister habberg kommt
von einem Inselurlaub und kann im Hafen
in Schleswig-Holstein nicht an Land
gehen weil wütende Landwirte unter
Androhung von Gewalt versuchen die fre
zu stürmen Geschehen gestern Abend
Bundesregierung Politiker fast aller
Parteien und deutscher Bauernverband
verurteilen die Aktion scharf seitdem
tobt eine Debatte über Radikalisierung
und Protestkultur Henna Hebestreit über
die Eskalation und
Reaktionen es ist der turbulente
Abschluss eines Kurzurlaubs auf
hallichhoge hunderte Demonstranten
hindern Bundeswirtschaftsminister Weg am
Verlassen einer nordseefähre begleitet
von Feuerwerk stechen Schiff und
Minister wieder in See Bundesregierung
und auch Oppositionspolitiker sind
empört aus meiner Sicht ein vollkommen
inakzeptables Verhalten und diese
Chaoten die dort unterwegs waren haben
dem Anliegen dort wirklich ein
Bärendienst erwiesen vor allem Landwirte
waren an der Aktion beteiligt die
offenbar Teil ist ihres Protestes gegen
subvenstionskürzungen der
Bundesregierung und die zeitweilig aus
dem Ruder gelaufen
war nach Darstellung der räderei konnten
der Kapitän der higen lei sowie die vor
Ort befindlichen Polizeikräfte eine
impulsive Erstürmung des Schiffes in
letzter Minute verhindern Vertreter vom
Bauernverband distanzieren sich und
bedauern dass der Minister auf einer
privaten Reise blockiert wurde wir haben
irgendwo gelesen dass habeg in schutel
ist so stand jedenfalls in dieser
Mitteilung zu einem Gesprächstermin
niemand hat gewusst dass er privat da
ist mit solchen Aufrufen in Foren für
Landwirte im Internet war zur Teilnahme
an einem vermeintlichen Bürgerdialog
aufgefordert worden es wurde ein
Feuerwerk versprochen der Umgang auf dem
Land wird immer ruppiker Bauern
beobachten dass unter den Kollegen Frust
und Wut immer stärker über soziale
Medien befeuert werden in der Form ist
es relativ neu in den letzten Monaten
den letzten ein zwei Jahren was da in
den sozialen Medien abgeht was man in
Statusmeldung von von Whatsapp sieht
oder so das ist für mich relativ neu
erst mit stundenlanger Verspätung konnte
Harbeck das Festland erreichen er will
das Gespräch suchen mit den Landwirten
die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt
wegen
Nötigung die gestrige Eskalation die
reih sich ein in eine ganze Serie von
Grenzüberschreitungen die es schon seit
einiger Zeit gibt sie reichen von
Gewaltandrohung bei Protestkundgebung
bis hin zu wüstenbeschimpfung und
Schmähungen im Netz was ist da
eigentlich ins Rutschen geraten und
warum dazu Julia
Schröter eine wütende Menge versucht die
Fähre mit Wirtschaftsminister habbeck an
Bord zu stürmen nur knapp kann die
Polizei sie zurückhalten hat diese Art
das Protests eine Grenze überschritten
wir ziehen in der protestforchon
eigentlich die Grenze da wo Gewalt
angewendet wird wenn vor allem Gewalt
gegen Menschen und quasi physische
Gewalt gegen Menschen aber auch digital
stattfindet dann sprechen wir
normalerweise nicht mehr von legitimen
Protest die Wut der Bauern das steht
fest ist groß auch vor drastischen
Symbolen wie diesen der Ampel am Galgen
wird in einigen Orten nicht
zurückgeschreckt nicht nur Robert
habbeck bekam gestern Wut zu spüren
sondern auch der Bundeskanzler bei
seinem Besuch im Flutgebiet in
SachsenAnhalt wurde Olaf Scholz
lautstark zu verstehen gegeben dass er
nicht erwünscht
sei
verschwind
lüg
die Stimmung die der Kanzler zu spüren
bekommt ist feindselig und für
protestforscher nicht
überraschend wir kommen aus der
coronakrise wir hatten dann quasi ein
Krieg in Europa eine Energiekrise und
jetzt haben wir ein eine eine harte
Haushaltssituation und das alles
zusammen baut Frustration in der
Bevölkerung das Braut eine gewisse das
das politische Vertrauen wird verloren
und das führt dazu dass diese
Kombination von unterschiedlichen
Faktoren eine gewisse Gewaltbereitschaft
Gewaltpotenzial tatsächlich
den nähboden liefert das Problem ist
nicht der Protest an sich sagt der
Forscher sondern wie protestiert wird
ein gewaltfreier Umgang miteinander das
wäre auch wichtig für die
Landtagswahlkämpfe in diesem
Jahr gehen die Bauern zu weit fragen wir
bei ZDF heute live um 19:30 Uhr auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen wer habck
färe im Hafen blockierte wo der
demoauruf seinen anfangnahen und wer für
den Protest warb das können Sie alles
nachlesen in unserer ZDF heute
App wie könnte eine Zukunft für die
Menschen in Gaza aussehen wenn der Krieg
gegen die Hamas vorbei ist Israels
Verteidigungsminister galant hat jetzt
seinen Plan skizziert zentraler Punkt
auch nach Kriegsende will Israel die
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit im
Gazastreifen übernehmen die Verwaltung
des Gebiets soll aber in die Hände der
Palästinenser gegeben werden und eine
multinationale Taskforce unter
us-leitung soll den wieder aufbust
Steuern Michael
bewunge noch herrscht das Gesetz des
Krieges in Gaza Krieg gegen die
Terroristen der Hamas doch getroffen
werden nicht nur die wie die Videos der
israelischen Armee zeigen sollen sondern
auch die
Zivilbevölkerung dieser Vater weint um
sein Kind von Israel erwartet er nur das
[Musik]
schlimmste das sind Kriminelle und die
Mörder von Kindern wir haben mit all dem
nichts zu tun sie ermorden unsere Kinder
und Frauen die israelische Regierung
nimmt Demokratie und Menschlichkeit für
sich in Anspruch aber sie ist
unmenschlich Israels
Verteidigungsminister Galland hat nun
Eckpunkte für die Zeit nach dem Krieg
vorgestellt die wichtigsten Punkte
komplette Kontrolle durch das
israelische Militär vorerst zivile
Selbstverwaltung auf lokaler Ebene durch
unbelastete palä er und wieder Aufbau
mit Hilfe einer internationalen
Taskforce Deutschland der wichtigste
Partner in Europa reagiert erstmal
zurückhaltend es darf keine Besetzung
des Gazastreifens geben keine
Vertreibung und keine Verkleinerung des
Territoriums zugleich darf für Israel
keine Gefahr aus dem gaserstreifen mehr
ausgehen noch sind viele Fragen für den
Tag danach offen und damit die Zukunft
der ganzen
Region da wollen wir Nachfragen bei
Michael bewunge in Tel Aviv Michael wie
viel Chancen hat der galantplan auf
politische
Umsetzung natürlich ist das Konzept von
Galland noch voller Widersprüche und
weiß viele Lehrstellen auf aber zum
ersten Mal in diesem Krieg hat ein
ranghohes Mitglied der Regierung dazu
noch der zuständige Minister zumindest
mal eine grobe Skizze vorgelegt wie denn
eine Nachkriegsordnung für Gaza aussehen
könnte da sind natürlich noch frer viele
Fragen offen z.B wie lange soll denn
diese vorläufige quasi Besatzung durch
Israel erstmal andauern wird es eine
Abriegelung des gasastreifens geben wird
es zur Vertreibung oder zur erzwungenen
Umsiedlung von Palästinensern dort
kommen was ist mit den lokalen Beamten
wie weiß man nach dass die nichts mit
der Hamas zu tun hatten und natürlich
auch die Rolle der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde die USA sehen Sie gerne
dort in einer größeren Rolle als das
Premierminister Netanyahu will und dann
ist natürlich die ganz große Frage wie
wird denn das Ganze zu einer vielleicht
noch größeren Friedensordnung Gaza und
Westjordanland zusammengebunden damit
diese Region endlich mal eine friedliche
Perspektive hat Michael hab vielen Dank
nach Tel Aviv jetzt zum Tarifkonflikt
bei der Bahn da kommt das Unternehmen
der lockführergewerkschaft GDL entgegen
und ist jetzt doch zur Verkürzung der
Wochenarbeitszeit bereit die GDL hatte
für Schichtarbeiter 35 statt bisher 38
Stunden bei vollem Lohnausgleich
gefordert die Bahn bietet jetzt ein
wahlmodell mit einem Korridor zwischen
35 und 40 Stunden an allerdings bei
entsprechend weniger Lohn für Mittwoch
lädt die Bahn die GDL zu neuen
Verhandlungen
ein es war ein Überbleibsel aus der
coronazeit der ermäßigte
Mehrwertsteuersatz für die Gastronomie
jetzt werden in den Restaurants statt 7
wieder 19% für speisenfällig und darum
haben viele Wirte im neuen Jahr die
Speisekarten neu gedruckt und die Preise
teils kräftig erhöht so hat kaldi
berichtet Pasta mit rinnfleisch und
Garnelen im kila Restaurant Nil
aktueller Kurs
21,50 ab Februar wird Betreiber
Konstantin Kocher bei den Preis der
Pasta erhöhen auf3
2091 ein Plus von 2,41
die große Befürchtung ist dass die Gäste
ausbleiben und nicht mehr bereit sind
die Preise die wir brauchen um
wirtschaftlich zu bleiben zu bezahlen
der Gaststättenverband befürchtet eine
Pleite Welle die Branche leider ohnehin
unter steigenden Kosten deswegen sollten
die 7% beibehalten werden es geht auch
um Steuergerechtigkeit im Verhältnis zu
den Bäckern Schlachtern Tankstellen bist
tros etc außer Haus Service die Zahlen
7% eine dauerhafte Senkung der Steuer
würde jährlich 3 Milliarden Euro kosten
so Fachleute die 7% seien in der
Pandemie und Energiekrise eine richtige
Maßnahme gewesen aber die Lage nun eine
andere die
Rechtfertigungsgründe sind weggefallen
und die aktuellen Herausforderungen
treffen alle Branchen dann sollte man
nicht mit einem selektiven Instrument
eine Branche
begünstigen bleibt die Hoffnung dass die
Gäste trotz steigender Preise auf
Restaurantbesuche verzichten
wollen er begann als einzelner Optiker
und schuf ein ganzes brillenimperium
Günther Fielmann gilt als einer der
erfolgreichsten deutschen Unternehmer
und es starb jetzt mit 84 Jahren felmann
eröffnete 1972 in kuckshafen sein erstes
Geschäft und brachte bald die gesamte
Zunft gegen sich auf denn er machte
modische Brillengestelle auch für
kleinere Geldbeutel erschwinglich heute
hat seine mehr als 23 000 Mitarbeiter
und sieht sich weltweit als Nummer 3 der
Augenoptik
Branche unter großer Anteilnahme ist
Wolfgang Schäuble heute in seiner
Heimatstadt Orenburg beigesetzt worden
an der Trauerfeier in der Stadtkirche
nahmen neben der Familie auch zahlreiche
Politiker Teil sie würdigten den
früheren Bundestagspräsidenten als einen
der bedeutendsten Politiker der
Bundesrepublik Schäuble war am zweiten
Weihnachtstag mit 81 Jahren ben Luisa
Huben
berichtet sie sind gekommen um Abschied
zu nehmen von einem vertrauten einem
Freund einem großen Staatsmann von
Wolfgang Schäuble wir müssen Wolfgang
Schäuble hergeben und hätten ihn noch so
gerne bei uns gehabt am zweiten
Weihnachtsfeiertag war Schäuble mit 81
gestorben noch am Heiligabend hatte er
selbst hier in der Stadtkirche Offenburg
ein letztes Mal Gottesdienst gefeiert
der heutige dem Zeichen der Dankbarkeit
für schäupeles Leben wirken und die
gemeinsame Zeit wir verneigen uns mit
großem Respekt mit
Dankbarkeit und mit Zuneigung vor
Wolfgang Schäuble einem großen Sohn
unseres
Landes als Bundestagspräsident
Innenminister Finanzminister hatte
Schäuble mehr als 50 Jahre deutsche
Politik geprägt immer an seiner Seite
seine Frau Ingeborg und die vier
Kinder du hast uns gezeigt dass sich die
starken um die schwächeren kümmern
müssen du hast uns gezeigt dass man nach
Niederlagen wieder aufstehen kann du
hast uns gezeigt dass man sich selber
nicht so wichtig nehmen soll und du hast
uns gezeigt was mit Wille möglich ist
papa du warst ein
Gesamtkunstwerk tausende säumten die
Straßen als sein sag zum waldbachfedhof
getragen wurde dort liegt Wolfgang
schäuple nun
begraben
zwei Kriege im Nahen Osten und in der
Ukraine da geraten andere Konflikte und
daraus resultierende Konsequenzen aus
dem Blickfeld z.B dieser hier es geht um
den Sudan im Nordosten von Afrika 2021
putschte dort das Militär danach
entbrannte ein Konflikt zwischen zwei
Generälen der im vergangenen Jahr dann
eskalierte und seitdem kämpft die Armee
unter Machthaber al bururhan gegen den
ehemaligen Vize daglo und Miliz mehr als
7 Millionen Menschen sind auf der Flucht
das Internationale Rote Kreuz spricht
von einer katastrophalen humanitären
Situation mehr von goline
atai sie plündern rauben und
vergewaltigen systematisch Frauen und
Mädchen die Milizen des Generals
Mohammed Hamdan daglo sind auf einem
Siegeszug in
Sudan Nabil ahm arztassistent aus dem
Westen Sudans und nun in den sch
geflohen hat ethnische Säuberungen
erlebt als Milizen sein Krankenhaus
Einnahmen er wurde festgenommen
gefoltert und Augenzeuge von
massak ich habe gesehen wie die Milizen
20 30 lebende Menschen in einen Graben
geworfen haben und dann einige gezwungen
haben die anderen lebendig zu
begraben die Paramilitärs Filmen ihre
mordzüge oft selbst auch den Graben in
dem Nabil ahm die grausame
in einem Kinderkrankenhaus im westsudan
W ein Kind gefahrlos hierherbringen und
sich eine Behandlung leisten kann gehört
zu den Glücklichen dreieinhalb Millionen
Kinder unter 5 Jahren sind mittlerweile
unterernährt wir haben einen Mangel an
Fertignahrung für unterernährte wir
können daher derzeit nur absolute
Notfälle
aufnehmen Sudans zweitgrößte Stadt
aus der hauptstadartum hierher
vertriebene müssen erneut fliehen weil
die Paramilitärs immer mehr Landesteile
erobern Einwohner die es nicht
rechtzeitig hinausschafften erleben
unter den neuen Machthabern Gewalt und
Willkür jedes Mal wenn wir an einen Ort
gehen den wir sicher glaubten ändern
sich die Dinge am nächsten Tag wo sollen
wir nun
hinohinag die UN sprchenon
vertreibungskrise der Welt der Sudan
steht vor dem
Zusammenbruch der frühere
südafrikanische sprinster Oscar
Pistorius ist aus der Haft entlassen
worden auf Bewährung der 37-Jährige lebt
zunächst im Haus eines Onkels dass er
nur mit Erlaubnis verlassen darf der
ehemalige Ausnahmeathlet der beide
Unterschenkel amputiert hat steht noch 5
Jahre unter Aufsicht er hatte 2013 seine
Freundin Rivers Team Camp mit vier
Schüssen durch eine Tür getötet
Pistorius war wegen Todschlags zu 13
Jahren und 5 Monaten Haft verurteilt
worden ein Feuer in einer Klinik in der
niedersächsischen Stadt ölsen hat
mindestens fünf Patientinnen und
Patienten das Leben gekostet mehr als
ein Dutzend Menschen wurden zum Teil
schwer verletzt der Brand brach gestern
Abend im dritten Stock aus und griff auf
mehrere Zimmer über die Ursache ist noch
unklar und 140 Einsatzkräfte retteten
mehrere Patienten aus ihren Zimmern
teils
überleitern jetzt zum Hochwasser in
weiten Teilen Deutschlands beim Blick in
den Himmel da keimt ein wenig Hoffnung
auf der Dauerregen jedenfalls ist wohl
erstmal vorbei aber es wird dauern bis
das Wasser abgelaufen ist und solange
bleibt die Lage trotz Hilfe und großer
Solidarität an den durchweichten Deichen
auch weiter brisant Christian Volk
berichtet in Hagen grrinden in
Niedersachsen lassen Sie sich vom
Hochwasser nicht aus der Ruhe bringen
mehr als eineinhalb Wochen waren die
Bewohner von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
teils ohne Strom ohne Kanalisation und
noch immer steht das Wasser seit Tagen
hilft hier jeder jedem einige die neu
sind im Dorf die sind dadurch eigentlich
erst so richtig in unsere tolle
Gemeinschaft reingekommen und das war
einfach eine tolle Erfahrung für die
aber auch für uns Silvester sind viele
der Dorfbewohner zusammen kommen mit dem
Boot oder mit wadhosen Zusammenhalt
stärkt das ist auch das Motto in Alden
in Niedersachsen stundenlang schleppen
Einsatzkräfte und Helfer in der Nacht
Sandsäcke insgesamt sind es 60 000 Stück
sie sorgen dafür dass eine Straße nicht
durch die Wassermassen
absackt wir haben zurzeit jetzt gerade
in der Nachttemperaturen um den
Gefrierpunkt herum die sind natürlich
für die Einsatzkräfte entsprechend
belastend gerade für die Kameraden
Kameradin der DLG die hier auch im
Wasser tätig sind in Sangerhausen in
Sachsen-Anhalt haben die Anwohner Angst
vor einem durchgeweichten Damm damit der
nicht bricht ist nun erstmals auch die
Bundeswehr mit etwa 2000 Soldaten im
Einsatz Hauptaufgabe hunderttausende
Sandsäcke befüllen und verteilen wir
sind im Prinzip jetzt diejenigen die für
die zivilen Einsatzkräfte für ein
bisschen für Entlastung sorgen und wir
haben natürlich auch die Möglichkeit
ordentlich mit Manpower aber eben auch
mit Technik also speziell Gelände ging
hier ein LKW
an die Arbeitsorte zu fahren etwa
eineinhalb Wochen sollen die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten zunächst vor Ort in
Sangerhausen bleiben und
mithelfen ja quasi von ultranass zu
ultraakalt wie derzeit in fast ganz
Skandinavien Tageshöchsttemperaturen
dort etwa
-25° im Süden Schwedens blieben
Lastwagen stecken im Norden musste in
etwa 4000 Haushalten der Strom
abgestellt werden in Finnland wurden
nachtstemperaturen von
-42° gemessen ab Sonntag soll es dann
milder werden dann kommt die Kälte über
Russland und das baltigkum zu uns nach
Deutschland jetzt sind wir beim Sport
beim skispring Christin und für Andreas
Wellinger gab es da bei der vier
Schanzen turn einen kleinen Dämpfer ja
gibt sich aber weiter recht cool Platz 9
in der Qualifikation für Andreas
Wellinger am Tag vor dem großen Showdown
der Tournee in Bischofshofen wohl wissen
dass ein Konkurrent der Gesamtführende
rioyo Kobayashi aus Japan souverän am
weitesten
flog Kopfschütteln bei Andreas Wellinger
der qualifikationssprung in
Bischofshofen misslinkt weil er am
Schanzentisch viel zu spät agiert und so
nur auf 128 m kommt das reicht lediglich
zu Rang 9 weit hinter dem tneeführenden
Japaner rioyu Kobayashi der mit
138 m die größte Weite des Tages schafft
stolze 10 m weiter als Wellinger das
heiß lang ist schpringen Tagesform
braucht richtige Gefühl und man muss
dann einfach in Rhythmus in den Flor
reinkommen der am Ende weit fliegt und
das werden wir für morgen vornehmen die
Hoffnung bleibt also bei Wellinger
zweieinhalb Meter muss er aufholen
vielleicht kommt ihm ja der für morgen
angesagte Regen zu Hilfe beim
tourneefinale mit zwei Podestplätzen für
die deutschen begann ziemlich
eindrucksvoll der Biathlon Weltcup in
Oberhof Thüringen zuerst gewann Benedikt
doll den Sprint der Männer und im
Anschluss wurde Franziska preus bei den
Frauen zweite es ist richtig gut
gelaufen für Benedik doll fast perfekt
sogar das erste schießen top doch beim
zweiten trifft er mit dem fünften Schuss
nicht ins Schwarze doll geht trotzdem in
Führung muss aber auf Fehler der
Konkurrenz hoffen muss ehrlich sagen ich
war heute ein bisschen
überrascht dass ich nach dem zweiten
Schießen als nach dem stehen schießen in
Führung lag eigentlich habe ich gedacht
der johannesing hat null geschossen doch
der Norweger schießt zweimal daneben
sein Landsmann Holm einmal und Benedikt
doll feiert mit 1,8 Sekunden Vorsprung
auf lagret seinen zweiten Sprintsieg der
Saison bei den Frauen bleibt Franziska
preus beim Schießen fehlerfrei in der
Lupe verliert sie aber Zeit dennoch ist
nur die Französin Justine bris B
schneller als die deutsche und
gewinnt ja und Down Under steht das
deutsche Tennisteam beim United Cup in
Sydney im Halbfinale nach dem Erfolg von
Alexander SF und der Niederlage von
Angeli Kerbe in den einzelnen sichert
sierf gemeinsam mit Laura Siegemund im
entscheidenden Mix Doppel das
Weiterkommen durch den zweisatzsi gegen
das Duo aus Griechenland morgen wartet
Gastgeber Australien t da muss dann
schon alles klappen dann vielen Dank
Christin wir hatten es gerade schon
angedeutet es wird kälter und es fällt
häufiger Schnee Details zum
Wochenendwetter gibt's gleich von Katja
horneffer Landwirtschaftsminister öst
mir ab 22 Uhr im heute journalinterview
mit Christian Siebers das gesamte 19 Uhr
heute Team bedankt sich fürs zuschauen
und wünscht einen angenehmen Start ins
[Musik]
Wochenende guten Abend das Tief das den
Alpen viel Schnee bringt zieht bis
Sonntag Abend weiter nach Osten und dann
dominiert bei uns in Mitteleuropa dieses
hoch und das bringt sehr tiefe
Temperaturen mit und sorgt auch dafür
dass es von Norden immer sonniger wird
heute Nacht müssen sie sich noch auf
glatte Straßen einstellen im Norden denn
dort fällt Schnee aber auch am Alpenrand
denn da zieht der Schnee langsam weiter
nordwärts am ersten trocken bleibt die
Nacht hier zwischen Sachsen und dem
saarand die Temperaturen dazu sinken auf
4° am Rhein und bis -2° im Nordosten und
morgen liegen dann die
Höchsttemperaturen rund um die uermark
bei dauerfrostigen -1° milder wird's am
Mittel und am oberrehein mit 6° und auch
morgen sollten Sie sich noch auf Schnee
gefasst machen hier in Norddeutschland
und auch im Alpenvorland gibt's weitere
Schneefälle am ehesten trocken ist es
noch zwischen der neie und der Mosel und
auch am Sonntag fällt noch Schnee im
Alpenvorland dann aber setzt sich von
Norden immer häufiger die Sonne durch
und es wird merärklich kälter am
Dienstag bei Höchsttemperaturen von -7
bis +2° guten Abend